(electronic sound popping)
- You know as anyone
will tell ya',
I'm a lover of the
finer things in life,
incredible outfits,
exotic bilingual women
and Guy Fieri's American
Kitchen and Bar in New York City
recipient of three
Michelin Tires.
As a possessor
of one of the most sophisticated
palettes of all-time,
I'm gonna offer my critique
of some of Guy's most
legendary dishes.
(water spitting)
(annoyed grunt) Horse piss.
(spitting)
Ah, Dragon's Breath
Chili, let's see.
(intrigued grunt)
This has some interesting notes,
kind of like licking the floor
of your drunk uncle's rec room.
A hint of an ashtray
at a dog track.
There's definitely
a taint element,
but I can't put my finger
on who's taint it is.
George Stephanopoulos's
pinky ring
and bull semen, I knew it.
You know, they say each
rack of Motley Que Ribs
is painstakingly marinated
in a stripper's bathtub.
(intrigued grunt)
Got a nice tang to it.
You can really
taste the Sudafed.
Horse.
(excited grunt) Lucky me.
I think I found a piece
of Guy's soul patch.
He really is a hands-on chef.
(wind blowing)
You know it's better this way.
Now one of Shakespeare's fools
was this tastefully
realizes this one
of the salted whiskey
caramel variety
and yes, I'm including
Bottom the weaver.
(laughing)
(coughing)
This would pair well with
subtle spirit as digestif.
(relaxed grunt)
That's the stuff.
The Guy-talian Nachos
are a wonderful blend
of sausage, beef and ricotta
on fucking tortilla chips.
Reminds me of that
one time in Italy
when a lusty divorcee
of advanced age took
me as her lover,
looked a lot like this.
Also, she too gave me diarrhea.
A variety of condiments
have been provided for
the Volcano Chicken.
Flavor, according to taste.
Need a little bit more.
(whiskey splashing)
(spitting)
I don't think I
should be driving.
(keys jingling)
(grunting)
Looks like my fried ice cream
has been aged by
the hot autumn sun.
It don't make no matter.
(intrigued grunt)
(straw sucking)
Here's a fun fact, they
say it's the only ice cream
that's been fried with
a Firestone car battery.
Not your best work Mr. Fieri.
I mean, sure ya'
fried ice cream,
but why not add a pocket
of blue cheese dressing
or maybe a drizzle
of nacho cheese sauce
or maybe a pair of
gin-soaked board shorts.
I believed in you God damn it.
(spitting)
This is Dave Hill At Midnight's
food critic signing off.
Now if you'll excuse me,
I'm gonna go hit the
can for 12 hours.
Oh God.